je vais pas fait le tour de la pointe en
ramant à cet instant précis
le miracle voilà c est pourtant j jamais
cru au miracle
en 1987 j'ai sauvé un gamin de 8 ans de
la noyade est plus années plus tard j'ai
découvert que notre voyage ensemble et
ait le droit de s'arrêter là ça va ton
père m'a écrit une lettre il ya déjà un
bail
qu'est ce qu'elle disait je ne sais rien
jamais ouverte j'admire depuis qu'il est
tout petit
tu ne vois pas quel point il a besoin de
toi
l'expert en eau depuis toujours leader
le truc qui te fait dire
pour cette raison là que je suis sur
terre
qu est ce que tu parles la vague la plus
des normes du monde
[Musique]
on ne sait pas qu'il est gamin sans
entraînement non pas sur le ring avec
mike tyson
il va surfer cette vague même s'il doit
laisser sa vie
comme tu le ferais je vais t'entraîner à
survivre parce que je veux pas morte à
mort sur la conscience il veut te lancer
à l'assaut de la vague
alors oubliez les douleurs
la vague mavericks peut-on maintenir
sous l'eau pendant plusieurs minutes
d'affilée
la respiration pendant au moins quatre
minutes je n'aime pas la peine d'essayer
cette fois je vais faire comme s'il ne
s'était rien passé
genève un boulot il reste deux minutes
les bars à sa cour
alors monsieur le surfeur qui va
terrasser le dragon tout seul ou tempère
de location va s'en charger pour toi
qu'est ce qui te ronge à l'intérieur
j'ai de quoi tu as peur c'est ta chance
de pouvoir tout changer
ces six là
richer
[Musique]
l'important c'est pas uniquement le surf
mais aussi des choix qu'on fait dans la
ville
[Musique]
fait de trouver le truc
béret
il faut que tu crois toi
tout ça n'aurait servi à rien
[Musique]